hello my name is janae badger and i'm
the chief medical scientist at microsoft
research joining you today from our
microsoft research lab in cambridge in
the united kingdom
welcome to day one of the health and
life science track of the microsoft
research summit
there has never been a more
consequential time to be working as a
member of the research community in
health and life sciences
research and technological developments
in health and life sciences have the
potential to fundamentally transform the
value that we can create for science and
humanity
here at microsoft our aim is to help
ensure that every person on the planet
can live to their physical and mental
potential by advancing inclusive and
equitable technologies supporting the
health of individuals and populations
our investments across the organization
in research and development
world-class talent and strategic
partnership
reflect our ceo satya nadella's vision
that many of the next health
breakthroughs will come from health and
life sciences organizations working in
partnership with technology companies
by collaborating across different
disciplines and institutions at the
intersections of computing technology
health and life sciences we're
developing and applying technological
advancements to transform healthcare and
empower people around the globe to lead
healthier lives
we invite our microsoft research summit
participants to join us in envisaging
strategies that focus on two
interrelated types of impact
health discovery and health delivery
on day one in the health and life
sciences discovery track we will explore
the acceleration of data and compute
driven methodologies for diagnostic and
therapeutic innovation
on day two in the health and life
sciences delivery track we will explore
the role of research and innovation and
dismantling barriers to health equity
increasing access to health care
strengthening resilience and
transforming the delivery of healthcare
across geographies through new category
defining technologies and experiences
for both types of impact for science and
for society we believe in marrying
research and implementation from the
start by working with partners that
reflect the communities for which we are
trying to effect change towards
ambitious but achievable goals
at microsoft we aim to raise the bar in
both regards what counts as ambitious
and what counts as achievable
diving a little bit deeper into what you
can expect on day one
today we're looking at data and compute
or aei driven methodologies for
diagnostic and therapeutic innovation
from an industry perspective this
tackles problems of our pharmaceutical
biotech and medical technology partners
and our customers
we are also learning building and
shaping interdisciplinary innovation and
incubation approaches to help create the
right environment tools and catalysts to
achieve transformative change
across our research labs and incubations
and through extensive partnerships we
have been exploring ways in which such
methodologies advance the state of the
art reacting to urgent needs brought
forth by the pandemic
and ensuring the technologies and
products developed are responsible
representative and equitable
we're honored to have all of our guests
but i would like to call out two special
leaders who are pushing the limits in
biotechnology and precision healthcare
who will be joining us in the fireside
chats
new baratheon and mike rosenblatt from
flagship pioneering
newbar and mike are both incredible
humanitarians and distinguished leaders
in the biopharma space
at flagship they're systematically
creating science-based innovations and
breakthroughs that serve as the
foundation for improving the human
condition
my thanks to you all for joining us
today and tomorrow